nouveau podcast consacré à un prospect
clé de la draft NBA 2023 et on va
prendre de la hauteur sur celui-ci notre
profil en 20 minutes et consacré à Derek
Lively
Derek Lively joueur de Duke Blue Devils
cette année en NCIS sa seule année en
NCA puisqu'il est né le 12 février 2004
il a donc 19 ans il aura 19 ans le soir
de la draftage minimum requis deux
mètres 16 je disais qu'on allait prendre
de la hauteur de mettre 16 104 kg pour
Derek Lively un pivot mobile très grand
donc très long et pour en parler nous
avons notre long Hugues et notre grand
Thomas salut à toutes et à tous
bonjour à tous
Hugues qui est Derek Jérôme Lively
puisque j'ai vu que son deuxième prénom
était Jérôme et ben écoute Lively 2
c'est pas junior c'est deux
ça veut dire que c'est après junior de
pour expliquer quand même
ouais ça veut dire que ils sont perd
c'est déjà junior en France
quand tu arrives à la préfecture la
convention
qui est né en aucun Philadelphie en
Pennsylvania il a fait son son High
School là-bas il a joué à Weston School
qui est pas un énorme lycée d'ailleurs
si vous voulez regarder du match au
niveau lycéen ce que j'ai essayé de
faire c'était assez affreux parce que tu
avais toujours des caméras tribunes
dignes d'une soirée vraiment multisport
à Bobigny c'était pas c'était pas
évident c'est un garçon qui a été
très vite convoité lors de ces années
High School par des programmes comme
Kentucky Michigan State un peu donc de
tous du I major qui était le lycéen
numéro 1 pour y ESPN 2 pour 247 sport 3
20 3 chez raivals donc vraiment c'était
un des prospects les plus attendus chez
nous envergure on n'était pas hyper
d'accord avec ça par notre visionnage et
c'est ce qui est un peu ressorti du côté
de sa saison NCIS c'est pas un jour
aujourd'hui on parle dans le top 5 de
sadraft au niveau de la famille faut
j'ai appris que le garçon avait une
enfance assez compliqué son papa est
mort d'une overdose cocaïne héroïne donc
je sais pas quel âge il avait mais ça
devrait ça a dû quand même forcément
impacté et sa maman se bat pour un
concert depuis 8 ans donc tu as un jeune
garçon avec comment dire un lourd poids
sur
épaules et sur cette très grande taille
et pour qui je pense devenir joueur
professionnel ça peut être aussi un
moyen de peut-être de sauver sa famille
donc ça explique peut-être le côté
visage assez fermé du joueur sur le
terrain c'est pas un mec qui respire la
joie de vivre et je peux comprendre
quand à ce bac
Lively j'ai pas précisé durant
l'introduction nous l'avons chez
envergure un peu plus bas en moyenne que
les autres que les médias américains en
termes de ranking même si il pourrait
remonter là on est le 14 juin donc on
n'a pas encore bouclé nos nos
classements d'avant draft nous l'avons
22e en moyenne l'âme c'est la moyenne de
nos 5 classement il est 13e chez
ispienne chez the Ringer aussi 14e chez
seatletic donc plutôt fin de loterie
borderline l'Autriche et les autres
Derek Lively quel rôle avait-il à Duke
très peu de ballons touchés cette année
pour lui et Thomas très peu de ballons
touché un taux d'usage de seulement 13%
donc extrêmement limité à dire qu'il
jouait pas énormément et je vais 20
minutes par match notamment à cause de
fautes de problèmes de fautes assez
récurrents on va en reparler après
offensivement c'est simple il a mis 77
paniers cette année il a mis 54 dunks
donc voilà pas besoin de vous faire un
dessin il fait de mettre 15 on lui
envoyer la balle en l'air et il donne ça
férocement donc c'était quasiment son
unique son unique à part offensif même
si c'est mon train intéressant sur
situation short roll pour pour faire un
peu le ce rôle de connectant en tant que
en tant que pivot pour pour espacer le
jeu pour les shooter de Duke
défensivement on avait une combinaison
intéressante donc Philippe poloski qui
qui sortait plus à l'extérieur également
à Seven footer qui s'occupait un peu
plus d'aller à l'extérieur et Derek
Lively en tant que très très fort
protecteur de ça il faut reconnu depuis
plusieurs années rester principalement
sur la sauter fonder principalement le
pic and roll et cueillez
adverse en les montrant avec un gros
gros taux de contre il est à plus de 2,4
contre en 20 minutes de temps le jeu et
on a un joueur qui monte une mobilité
assez intéressante pour pour sa taille
qui lui a permis de de proposer des
situations de défense au périmètre
vraiment intéressant pour un joueur de 2
mètres 15 mais donc niveau contexte un
jour qui met des dunks qui essayent de
s'écarter un petit peu par moments on
sait qu'on aille ce qu'on en reparlera
et s'écartait s'écartait bien plus
quelques petites passent mais surtout tu
dunk du contre c'est vraiment ce rôle
assez limité pour pondérer cette saison
et du coup Hugues ce rôle ben finalement
c'est sa carte d'entrée en NBA il en a
pas trop d'autres ouais c'est ça c'est
un grand qui va poser des écrans qui va
rouler au panier et qui va donne camion
va surtout la tendre défensivement je
suis toujours assez dur avec les jeunes
Américains sur la pose d'écran c'est un
défaut que je trouve souvent ils savent
pas poser des écrans corrects dans leur
jeune formation lui c'est le faire donc
je pense que ça il va pouvoir la porter
dans les premières années et puis il a
un bon timing du contre et je trouve que
en progrès si on veut regarder un peu
l'évolution depuis le High School dans
le moteur et dans l'implication c'est
mieux alors High School il prenait il
prenait des fois des grosses défaites et
ça aidait pas mais je trouve j'ai trouvé
là dans ces rotations dans son second
rideau plus plus préparé plus mobile
est-ce que il attendait beaucoup que le
ballon arrive devant lui pittant dès le
bras il giflé il disait allez on
contre-attaque là il y avait vraiment de
l'implication des des bons appuis de la
chargement de direction des bonnes
rotations du second rideau donc il y a
eu des progrès dans sa compréhension du
jeu et c'est bon signe pour pour une
arrivée en NBA dans deux trois ans pour
pouvoir vraiment apporter
à quel point en fait il est un bon
protecteur de cercle Thomas à quel point
parce que c'est sur ça que ça se joue en
fait si tu es expert dans un truc il
faut que tu sois dans les je sais pas
dans les cinq ou dix meilleurs NBA pour
avoir une valeur est-ce que lui il a ce
potentiel là d'être vraiment protecteur
de cercle quasi générationnel pour une
franchisement il y a notamment un match
qui a vraiment débloqué sa saison c'est
ce gros duel contre juvents où il pose
huit contre et à partir de là et c'est
mis à jouer 26 minutes par match donc
bien plus que ça mène de 20 minutes sur
l'année à plus de trois comptes de
moyenne donc on a vraiment un protecteur
de cercle qui brille par sa mobilité car
par sa capacité à couvrir de l'espace il
est non verdure immense de plus de 2
mètres 30 donc il a vraiment une énorme
capacité à contrer la détailler
intéressant et encore quelques
irrégularités je trouve encore un peu
bourreau de défensivement mais la il a
des qualités de protection d'arceau avec
sa taille et son envergure sa mobilité
et son sens du compte vraiment assez
impressionnant ça genre qui monte à
l'arceau main droite main gauche il peut
tout dégager donc ce vraiment ce combo
de mobilité de longueur d'instin
défensif et vraiment très intéressant et
ça fait lui un des tout meilleurs tout
meilleurs défenseur de cette cuvée et
dans ce poste 5 vraiment très important
pour être large d'une défense c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très important
et je l'ai trouvé vraiment très très
impressionnant par séquence cette année
même si il y a eu ces petits problèmes
récurrents de fautes et parfois des
séquences ou web y avoir un corps de la
vraie régularité on voit qu'il a fait
que 19 ans clairement
est-ce que ça peut switcher sur sur des
petits
ça peut être un peu
il peut switcher sur des petits
personnes j'ai envie de dire peut
vraiment switcher sur sur des petits à
deux mètres 15 il a les capacités pour
pas être ridicule il a une mobilité
d'appuyer vraiment intéressante en
France sevenfooter il a des appuis assez
assez vif illégalement pas très très
lourd il fait toujours 100 kg donc ça
lui permet d'être encore assez vif
d'appui donc non c'est intéressant c'est
pas le joueur qui va se faire qui va se
faire complètement exposer sur au
périmètre en plus avec sa capacité à
recouvrir les espaces et sa longueur ça
peut lui permettre même s'il est un peu
dépassé de quand même pouvoir réussir à
protéger son cercle de manière très
intéressante
ce qui est intéressant c'est que malgré
qu'ils sont encore assez fins et même
s'il est très haut il est encaisse bien
le contact au niveau du bassin donc
c'est pas un joueur donc tu vas pouvoir
casser le centre de gravité si
facilement que ça il pourrait aller sur
des situations de piqu'n roll où il peut
te rappeler redescendre et même si
l'extérieur expérimenté vient essayer de
lui mettre un coup de ou une épaule en
bassin pour le faire reculer pour faire
dégager du cercle et terminé lui il va
plutôt bien encaisser ça donc il y a une
maturité physique sur sur ce côté là et
puis comme Thomas l'a dit comme il peut
contrer dès demain
qu'il a
cette polyvalence là ça va lui permettre
de bien s'en tirer dans plein de
situations même sur des dispositifs hors
drop
psychologiquement tu parlais de d'un
joueur assez fermé mais au-delà de ça
est-ce que c'est des attitudes plutôt
positives sur un terrain
j'ai pas ou en dehors en interview de ça
alors adju que il a il arrive comme le
gros prospect alors il y a toujours
plein de prospects mais c'est quand il
est post-it qui a une avance de maturité
dans son jeu et dans son corps qui a été
mis en avant par John shalers donc lui
il a il a un peu pati ça on l'a pas trop
vu se plaindre il a pas été trop frustré
mais c'est un c'est un joueur tu as
l'impression qu'en terme de moteur qui
soit devant qui soit derrière ça change
pas grand chose moi je l'ai pas vu
vraiment tu vois il est pas réaction je
l'ai pas je l'ai pas vu être expressif
je l'ai pas vu ce sur motivé je il a
fait ce qu'on lui a demandé de faire et
puis au niveau du lycée c'est pareil sur
le terrain tu t'ennuyais un petit peu
c'est c'est pas cool à dire mais tu le
regardes et puis bon bah tu as pas
l'impression qu'il est hyper investi il
est vraiment il vient pour faire le
boulot qu'on lui demande de faire
il a parfois demandé un peu de ballon
poste bas très peu parce que on n'est
pas beaucoup mais parfois et qu'il avait
des prises de position sur des petits il
a demandé des ballons postes bas on lui
a pas donné il tapait un peu des mains
et puis qu'on lui donnait la séquence
d'après en fait bah il a vraiment
tellement peu de fondamentaux dans le
jeu
dos panier que bah finalement ça a
capoté on leur donnait plus le ballon
donc
voilà ce qui est positif c'est que c'est
pas trop plein de sa situation à Duke
malgré le peu de temps de jeu et le fait
qu'il soit pas mis en avant ce qui est
moins positif c'est que tu le comment
dire tu le remarques pas
particulièrement je j'ai l'impression
que c'est une sorte de Jackson eyes mais
sans le côté folie pour un bien et pour
un mal parce que Jackson
est un phénomène spécimen particulier
mais on est sur ce profil athletic là
sur ce corps là sur des qualités très
similaires mais avec un mode veille
intéressant
Thomas qu'est-ce que est-ce que tu
penses qui peut jouer dès l'année
prochaine est-ce que tu penses qu'il
peut devenir autre chose que juste un
protecteur de cercle de question
alors je réponds dans le sens inverse
parce que si je pense qu'il peut se
développer offensivement oui clairement
comme l'a dit Hugues il a vraiment peu
de mauvais post il a un toucher vraiment
très faible assez robotique il a peu de
mauve il en avait déjà pas un iPhone
c'est pour ça que personnellement
j'étais assez surpris de le voir numéro
un tube hier soir qui avait pas non plus
une immense production offensive en ice
school c'était un joueur qui prenait
principalement par sa défense tout
simplement qu'on l'a fait cette année à
Dieu donc offensivement on passe est
vraiment compliqué sa main gauche et
quasiment inexistence même avec sa main
droite ça reste vraiment très faible il
est à moins de 50% je crois au Cercle
hors dingue cette année donc il faut te
mettre 15 c'est assez assez limité
maintenant ce que j'aime bien avec son
arsenal offensive déjà s'il a des vrais
vrais flashs de playmaking sur du short
roll il est vraiment intéressant il est
vraiment capable de lâcher des belles
passes il y a même un petit peu de
manipulation visuelle j'en ai vu fente
de passe dans le corner avec les yeux
finalement on trouve un shooter ouvert
car le défenseur a anticipé la rotation
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressant et
surtout l'intrigue c'est le shoot il
montrait sa main dans les moques car
elle a extrêmement bien shooté sur son
brevet et on a les sous on voit déjà un
joueur qui avait des vrais prémices de
shoot il est mécanique vraiment assez
fluide pour sa taille Ali why Biel donc
c'était il y a 2 ans il avait shooté à
28 % derrière l'arc donc ce qui est déjà
intéressant pour un genre de sa taille
ils sont en volume intéressant il avait
40 tentative allez voyager avec Jane
Duranne donc vraiment c'était une
faquette c'est une raquette assez
terrifiante pour pour les adversaires
offensivement comme défensivement donc
on a un joueur un peu un peu particulier
j'ai envie de dire il a pas touché il a
pas de move proche du cercle il est
vraiment qualification de dunk mais par
contre il a ses s'il te plaît making et
cet espoir de shoot même si la seulement
2 sur 15 qui montrait en High School et
qu'il a potentiellement encore avec
cette belle mécanique et son toucher
intéressant derrière
et pour répondre à la à la deuxième
question j'ai oublié d'y répondre est-ce
qu'il peut jouer défense peut jouer dès
sa saison roki vraiment déjà un peu de
malgré son impact défensif je trouve
qu'il reste encore assez brut il peut se
faire exposer face à des joueurs
vraiment impactant qui vont qui vont lui
rentrer dedans cette année on a pu le
voir très très grande difficulté contre
qui dit il s'est fait exclure en 20
minutes je pense que même s'il a il a
des qualités défensives assez
exceptionnelles il a encore assez brut
il a pris énormément de fautes cette
année soit il saute un corps trop il
baisse un peu les brins encore trop et
donc ce qui provoque des fautes même si
ça s'est amélioré durant la saison ce
qui a pu voir son temps de jeu augmenté
je trouve qu'il a encore un peu brut de
défensivement et vu qu'offensivement
même si on parle de shoots ça reste une
promesse encore assez lointaine il a un
peu de plein meeting mais vu qu'il met
quasiment que qui m'a encore assez
inefficace sociale j'ai un peu du mal en
comptant cette défense qui est vraiment
du très gros potentiel mais encore assez
brut j'ai un peu de mal à le voir
vraiment important sur sa saison qui
peut-être quelques minutes mais je pense
qu'il aura pas un très gros rôle l'an
prochain Hugues est-ce qu'on y croit
finalement Marc Williams a été drafté le
tri est-ce qu'on croit en Derek live
alors beaucoup moins que Mark William ça
qui est bon avait fait deux ans qui
avait beaucoup plus de beaucoup plus de
masse et beaucoup plus de comment dire
Daiku j'ai l'impression dans la
compréhension du jeu
est-ce que j'y crois
pas plus que ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on
l'achète premier tour parce que
un pivot remplaçant une billet ça coûte
en moyenne 5 millions de dollars je vais
essayer tes contrats sur deux ans tes
règles Lively fin de premier tour il va
te coûter 1,8 millions donc ça va se
faire en gros du du 7 millions sur
quatre ans reconductible donc c'est pour
ça que tu vas tu vas payer quoi et c'est
ça qui va t'apporter je pense au mieux
tu as un pivot titulaire d'une équipe
moyenne si il se développe bien mais que
sur les trois quatre premières années
c'est un remplaçant qui vient qui met
quelques contre il y a des soirées où il
fait des highlights parce qu'il a mis
trois blocs en 5 minutes puis le reste
du temps il est à 10 minutes
donc voilà je suis pas je suis pas un en
gros amour mais le profil et surtout la
rareté cette année de très grands pivots
à part notre ami notre ami Victor va
faire que des gens en fin de premier
tour peut-être ou entre 20 et 30 qui ont
besoin de de taille pas cher on va
pouvoir investir
Thomas pour l'instant tu l'as dit
septième sur ton bord c'est à peu près
le niveau auquel il va finir c'est à peu
près le niveau auquel il va finir elle
va pas trop bouger personnellement j'y
crois j'y crois quand même même si
j'étais tout à c'est légitime je pense
défensivement il est vraiment
impressionnant par c'est quand je trouve
il est encore assez brute comme je l'ai
dit il a des choses à apprendre il doit
progresser sur sa masse sur des
régularités défensives sur ses fautes
mais je trouve qu'il a vraiment un
potentiel très très
haut de ce côté là du terrain le ce
cette combinaison de taille de mobilité
de longueur d'instin au contraire
vraiment et vraiment très très
impressionnant je le trouve et
offensivement j'aime bien son passé même
s'il a pas de moi au Cercle c'est
tellement une menace de lobe incroyable
il est vraiment c'est vraiment une
énorme menace de lobby
il a un cache radio vraiment énorme il
est capable de tout donc c'est vraiment
très impressionnant il y a toujours
cette espoir du 3 points que j'ai vu
j'ai vu en High School j'aime bien sa
mécanique donc je pense qu'on peut
construire rabattu donc son impact
défensif tu peux pot entiellement
devenir très très haut je trouve si il
se développe bien plus ses promesses
offensives au shoot et au plat meking en
plus de savoir tout donner même si il
manque de move post bas et de finition
ouais ça me le fait acheter un petit peu
en dehors de la loterie très bien eu qui
demande dans notre chat privé le plafond
c'est Allen tu parles de Jared Allen
ou de un autre ami
je me demande tu vois je regardais comme
ça sur les profils physiques
un plafond un peu plus tanqué
déjà le garçon et non de ce genre de
profil très long qui compte qui avait
pas trop de Move et qu'il y en a
toujours pas très bien mais qui finit
dans le rôle et qui est devenu un
excellent défenseur de de drop ou de
zone là ça peut être le scénario idéal
en direct Allen parce que moi je vois
beaucoup de Jackson eyes mais
physiquement au niveau de la coupe de
cheveux il y a un peu comme ça mais
Jackson eyes étaient tellement Dingo que
on est sur un profil un peu plus un peu
plus terre à terre depuis classique
merci messieurs c'était l'essentiel sur
Derek Lively 2 et oui qui est c'est
rarement aussi bien que le 1 le 2
mais bon on fait avec ce qu'on a à jouer
de de Duke donc et qui sera très
probablement choisi au premier tour le
soir de la draft NBA
et bien on vous embrasse tous vous
pouvez retrouver tous nos profils sur
une playlist sur Youtube mais également
sur vos plateformes d'écoute favorites
on vous embrasse allez voir nos profils
écrit également sur envergure.co puisque
celui de Derrick Lively vient de sortir
on est le 14 juin à l'heure à laquelle
je dis ça ciao tout le monde